-Thank you so much
for being here.
I'm so happy you came back.
-Thank you.
-Yeah.
-I want to come back
one more time.
-You do?
-Yeah.
-Okay.
-In a little while.
-Really?
-Yes.
-You'll just surprise me?
-Yup.
-Can we talk about
your album, by the way?
Number one holiday album
right here, "Christmas."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Number one, doesn't get
bigger than number one.
-No.
-Congratulations.
-Thank you.
-Why is it taking so long
to put out a holiday album?
-Because I could --
Oh, because I couldn't --
This sounds so stupid.
I couldn't find myself in a --
I couldn't see myself
in a Christmas album.
And so I just said
to the record company
if you just leave me alone,
and...
Right,
and I -- and I was in my house.
I recorded most of it
in my house,
some of it in England
with my producer.
But I just picked out
these kind of songs
that don't necessarily
go together.
But when you put them together,
they're really good
and they're all --
It's just to have
a happy thing.
Chuck Berry, and Stevie sings
on the album with me.
He sings on the song.
-How did you get?
How did you get --
I mean, obviously you're Cher,
you just called.
But how did you get
Stevie Wonder to go
yeah, I'll do, what,
Christmas -- he'll do.
-No, I was so terrified.
I'm not kidding.
I was.
-You?
-I'm not kidding.
I was like, ooh.
I called him because, look,
I'd done the song,
but there was just some parts
of it that were just Stevie.
I couldn't find it
and it was just Stevie.
So I called him and -- and I
said, "Hi, Stevie, it's me.
And he said, hi,
and how are you?
And I was like, into it.
Well, see, this is what I want.
I know how are you,
but I just said
I've done your song and I --
but there are some parts
I can't do, I just can't do it.
And he said, "Okay,
consider it done."
It was like, well, "Do you not
want me to pitch it more?"
-He just said yes immediately.
-Yeah.
-And he was like, yeah,
I'll just redo the parts,
whatever parts you want
me to do.
-He didn't even know
what I wanted him to do.
I just said,
I'll send it to you.
And so -- and he did it.
It's so good.
Alright,
but that's not the cool part.
So at the end, in the middle
he says, is it my song?
And I went, well, yeah,
it's your song.
And then at the end
he said, "Hey,
Cher, Cher, Cher."
And I went, "What?"
He said, "Do you want me
to play harmonica?"
-Now the gift just keeps giving.
And you go, oh, my gosh.
Did you start crying?
-And the truth is no matter
what kind of mood I'm in,
when I hear him play
the harmonica, I can only smile.
But that's not the best part.
[ Laughter ]
So when I hung up, I ran around
my room, jumped on my bed.
I jumped up and down
and just kept screaming.
Stevie Wonder is going to be
on my album.
-[ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Just like a little kid.
-Yeah.
-It's phenomenal. There's so
many good jams on here.
"DJ Play a Christmas Song,"
by the way,
that's my jam.
I love that one.
That's my fave on this one.
Ooh, ooh, look at this.
Well, I mean, come on.
You thought of everything.
-No, but with Tyga,
and that's really cool.
-Tyga's a great one, too.
-Yeah.
And, um, oh, Darlene Love.
-Darlene Love.
Wait.
I have a little trivia
about this that I did not know.
This is -- So "Christmas
(Baby Please Come Home)."
♪ Christmas snow's coming down ♪
Right? So you do that
with Darlene Love.
You go that makes sense.
Great.
Turns out you sang backup
on the original.
-When I was 17.
-What?
[ Cheers and applause ]
I never -- I never knew that.
What was that like?
I mean, that's well.
-I got the -- I got the gig.
Well, Sonny had told
Phillip Spector
Cher sings, and he was like,
yeah, yeah, yeah.
But then one night Darlene's
car broke down and he said,
Sonny said, do you sing?
And while I'm trying to qualify,
he said, I just need to know
he's get out there.
So I went out
and I was terrified
because Phillip was asking
everybody what's your part.
And I was thinking
I don't know my part.
And I just singing,
I'm copying somebody.
And that was -- I did it.
He never did --
He never worked
without me again
until the last song I did was
"You Lost That Loving Feeling."
-Wow.
I have a picture of you.
This is you and Darlene Love
from that session.
How cool is that?
And now she's singing
on your album.
It's full circle.
-Yeah, it is.
It's kind of fantastic.
When you're in New York,
you never call me or ask
if you want to hang out or...
And I just think
that's kind of interesting.
What do you like to do?
What does Cher do in New York?
I read somewhere that
you love Serendipity 3.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, I've been
going there since I was 19.
-This place,
Serendipity 3,
and you get
the frozen hot chocolate.
Yeah.
-Anyways, it's one of my
favorite spots, but you can't
get in in the city.
Obviously you can get in.
-I can get in.
-You're Cher.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, you can go in there.
-No, but I've known them
since I was 19 years old.
I can get in
because I've got seniority.
[ Laughter ]
-You got -- you got.
-You have great teeth.
-I do?
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-But now you're
a little bit red.
-Yeah. No, yeah.
You have the Christmas album.
You have "Believe,"
the deluxe edition.
Look at this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is. Yeah.
-And then I --
-I feel like we're at
the Home Shopping Network.
-We're getting to the blenders.
When only have five left.
But you you're coming out
with your memoir.
-Yeah.
-And I want -- This is exciting.
-Ugh.
-No. What do you mean?
You know why?
Because I just
totally chickened out,
because I was --
I guess I was -- I don't know
what I was.
I just was totally
chickening out,
but I -- I didn't put in
some things that need to be in,
and they're not comfortable,
but they need to be in.
So I have to go
back and man up.
-You got to do it.
-Yeah.
-It's like it's
beyond therapy.
It's tough.
-Yeah.
-And also I've lived
too long and done too much.
And so it's like
it should be the encyclopedia,
not that you guys know
what that is.
-Do you have a title for it?
-No.
-Should we come up with one?
[ Audience shouting ]
-Oh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That could be.
a great game.
-Yeah, yeah.
How about --
Alright, wait, so how about...
Alright.
So you're going to -- you're
going to -- you're going to tell
some things that
you probably shouldn't tell.
-Yeah.
-Maybe "I Got Scoops, Babe."
[ Audience groans ]
Alright, that got groans.
-I'm totally set up
for this one, right?
I'm really tired from surfing
in the audience, okay?
[ Laughter ]
-That was amazing, by the way.
That was amazing what you did.
That was dangerous.
Please don't ever do that again.
-I'm not, and I'm old. I can't
be doing that kind of [bleep].
[ Laughter ]
-Well, I can't wait
to read the book,
and I'm just going
to say right now, yes.
-What do you mean?
-You're going to ask me
if you want my permission
should I be in your book,
and yes.
[ Laughter ]
If it's -- it's a big book.
If it's a big book, come on.
This Cher already said yes.
This Cher said yes.
This Cher already said yes,
I'm in the book.
Am I in the book.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
-Oh, how about this one?
-That Cher's pliable, okay?
[ Laughter ]
-Maybe Over Chering.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
I'm telling you.
I love you.
I always love seeing you.
I love having you on.
Congrats on the Christmas album.
I thought that we could maybe
do a little fun celebration
for -- for this album.
So I actually talked to the
people over at "Serendipity 3"
and had them make us
a frozen hot chocolate.
-Ooh.
-This is ice cold
from Serendipity 3.
Should we have a sip and cheers?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Cheers.-
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's really cold.
Really good.
That is Cher
right there, everybody.